et bonjour claude malhuret merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoints direct
sur ce plateau vous êtes sénateur de
l'allier président du groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
ici au sénat vous êtes membres
d'horizons ces mouvements des marchés
nippons va bien sûr en parler on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
jefferson des sports de sud ouest
aujourd'hui quatre salles bonjour oriane
bonjour tout de la durée bonjour peu
d'alluré avant de parler de l'actualité
avec vous on va bien sûr longuement
parlé vous avez reçu hier soir le prix
du sénateur de l'année de la part du
jury du trombinoscope on le voit sur ces
images
est-ce que c'est surtout l'orateur
malhuret qui a été récompensé hier soit
bien entouré c'est ce que c'est ce que
m'a dit nathalie mort et qui étaient les
journalistes chargés de me remettre le
prix chaque journaliste qu'on était le
prix un politique ils sont que je sois
les à cause des discours que je fais au
sénat et de ce point de vue là permettez
moi de vous remercier parce que
aujourd'hui les discours en moyenne vous
du harari chief il sera étonné moi-même
il faut environ un million de vues
maintenant moyen sur twitter sur youtube
etc et ce sont ceux que vous c'est vous
qui les qui est qu'il est lancée au
départ est évidemment avec le compte
twitter que vous avez avec une centaine
de milliers c'est ce qui m'a permis
alors que moi j'ai un compte twitter
mais je ne twitte pas mais c'est un son
original
effectivement mais parce que je me sers
de twitter pour comme vous pour
m'informer pour la vie politique et
journalistique évidents et nécessiterait
aujourd'hui mais si je me mets à tweeté
je peux plus rien
je mets ça c'est un peu ce que vous du
sénat c'est aussi un peu cette cette
inquiétude que vous avez vis-à-vis des
réseaux sociaux qui sont en danger pour
la démocratie pour vous alors c'est ça
le paradoxe c'est que ce prix ou les le
l'important une le nombre de vidéos qui
sont de mes discours qu'ils ont vu c'est
ce sont sur les réseaux sociaux que
j'appelle moi les réseaux anti sociaux
et dont je pense effectivement mais je
suis pas le seul à le penser c'est obama
qui l'a dit en premier et en dernier
dans d atlantic que c'est une ville est
exprimée expliqué il a utilisé les mêmes
mots vous c'est une menace pour les
démos si vous faites vous aussi vous
subissez des attaques sur réseaux
sociaux ce que vous faites un million de
vues mais en même temps derrière et
après quelqu'un à chaque fois quelques
unes plus de positif jeu vidéo kane
négative mais un
millier en moyenne ou plus comme les
autres élus qu'est ce que vous payez
pour une sécurité claude malhuret non
vous savez et menacent aussi oui oui des
menaces
des menaces des menaces de mort etc et
réseaux sociaux c'est ça aussi on se
lâche on fait n'importe quoi bon la
police le pont au sérieux puisque je
fais partie de ceux qui de temps en
temps pour laquelle on fait des rondes
et des surveillances etc
mais bon je laisse faire
jeu franchement j'ai passé une bonne
partie de ma vie à médecins sans
frontières du côté des khmers rouges des
talibans afghans ou des milices
libanaises bon c'est pas les c'est pas
les quelques les délais ne sais pas quoi
sur sur les réseaux sociaux les menaces
de mort sur les réseaux sociaux bon on
verra bien mais c'est pas je crois qu'il
ya un mouvement qui dit attention les
politiques sont sont menacés c'est le
climat est délétère et c'est moi je ne
prends plus tôt
plutôt avec avec philosophie
pour moi la menace démocratique
la démocratie croate et réseaux sociaux
c'est
c'est d'abord le dit sur le débat ceux
des tombereaux de fox news d'injures de
harcèlement ça c'est très grave et
deuxièmement évidemment on va on l'a vu
dans toutes les élections qui depuis
quatre ou cinq ans c'est les robots les
trolls des dictateurs et notamment de
poutine qui re industriel man
truck et sabotent les élections comme on
l'a vu aux états unis comment le club
existe et c'est comme on a vu la
tentative en 2017 et je suppose que ça
va que ça va recommencer donc ça oui ce
sont des graves menaces pour les
démocraties est d'ailleurs la preuve
c'est qu'aujourd'hui et démocratie se
porte un petit peu moins bien par
rapport au régime et libéraux aux
régimes totalitaires qu'après la chute
du mur il ya une trentaine d'années où
c'était la victoire définitive des
démocraties on s'est aperçu que ce
n'était pas le cas et aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment problématique n'est un
mouvement qui met sur les réseaux
sociaux que l'on pleure ses réseaux
sociaux c'est ce qu'on appelle lé convoi
de la liberté comme ce qui s'est passé
au canada il ya actuellement des
milliers de véhicules qui convergent de
plusieurs villes de france vers paris
ils ont prévu de se rassembler ce soir
et demain dans la capitale la
manifestation est interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris est-ce que
ça c'est un mouvement qui vous inquiète
est ce que pour vous il peut prendre de
l'ampleur à ce qui peut perdurer que je
pense que non je pense que ce mouvement
est devenu on en est dans une queue de
comète qui devient ridicule
petit à petit le mouvement des antilles
vax totalement injustifiée parce que la
politique de la france était la bonne et
de 90 % des gens sont d'accord et que ça
puisqu'ils sont plus actionner c'est la
démonstration même que ce mouvement
était
ridicule un mouvement de complotiste
pour une part un mouvement
moment de gens qui voulaient protester
contre tout contre le gouvernement et
c'est un amalgame d'extrême droite de
complot tissé de protestataires petit à
petit il s'est amenuisé au point que
vous pointez terreau la manifestation il
y avait plus personne ça fait trois ans
que les gilet jaune aux antilles backs
et
on a pris
partie d une partie une partie des gens
sont les mêmes et une partie non mais à
deux mois de la présidentielle vous
craignez pas qu'on ait un nouveau
mouvement social nouvelle expression de
la colère et que ce quinquennat n'a pas
été épargné sur ce point bien sûr que
c'est que c'est une possibilité mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'aurait la crise
sanitaire a été géré regardez la presse
internationale vicente a été géré en
france d'une manière je dirais pas
exemplaire parce que on peut jamais
digéré à 100% bien mais elle a été
plutôt bien géré la crise économique et
politique et ou peut-être deux ans nous
mais la crise économique
et social a été géré jusqu'à présent
tout le monde le reconnais de manière
extrêmement bonnes bien entendu un
problème de pouvoir d'achat c'est pas
rien mais c'est pas rien si ces français
qui ont du mal à fait pour qu'il la fin
du mois arrive le 10 du mois qui ont du
mal à payer leur plein d'essence qui ne
peuvent pas ce qu'ils veulent à leur
enfant
moi je pense
bien entendu tout cela est vrai et bien
entendu tout cela est dû à la une crise
sanitaire qui a entraîné une crise
économique et avec en plus quelque chose
que l'on peut rien c'est à dire
l'augmentation du prix du gaz largement
orchestrée par poutine pour des réponses
des raisons dont on parlera peut-être
aussi politique et géopolitique
mais face à cela et je le lis plus dans
la presse internationale à dire que dans
la presse française
tout le monde dit la france est un des
pays qui a le mieux ou le moins mal géré
cette crise qui ne l'empêchent que quand
vous êtes dans une crise quels que
soient les efforts que vous faites
il reste des problèmes cela dit et donc
je comprends bien et je comprends bien
que les gens qui ont des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat cela dit je ne la raison
pour laquelle je pense pas que le
mouvement
les mouvements de protestation se font
lorsque vous n'avez pas les moyens de
s'exprimer
lorsque c'est le seul moyen que vous
ayez d'exprimer votre inquiétude ou
autre colère or dans deux mois les
français vont avoir un moyen extrêmement
simple ils le savent exprimer leur
volonté ils pourront voter ils pourront
éventuellement vous leur dites
rendez-vous dans les urnes et j'ai envie
passage je me dis que dans leur tête je
pense qu'ils se disent si on a quelque
chose à dire si on a une vision de
l'avenir on va l'exprimer parfois qu'ont
certains en votant pour les extrêmes
parfois en votant pour des partis
républicains de droite ou de gauche donc
je me dis qu'en général les périodes
d'élection et notamment de l'élection
nationale présidentielle ou législative
s'il vient d'avoir deux c'est un moment
qui n'est pas propice à la protestation
sociale parce que on a une autre un
autre moyen
on verra bien pour le moment oui elles
font un score élevé mais pas plus que la
dernière fois pas plus qu'on est en 2010
cette aide en fait 40% sur gears des
sondages où
on avait dit qu'on lui serait une
réponse nationale il n'y a pas répondu
regardez regardez ce qui se passe dans
les pays démocratiques voisins regardez
ci passe aux etats-unis en angleterre
elle brésil etc
et ça c'est un vrai problème vous avez
où que ce soit à une montée des extrêmes
une menace sur les démocraties
et nous le rôle des politiques est
d'ailleurs permis à thomas dire dans le
rôle des journalistes devant
l'accumulation des fêtes news des
réseaux sociaux qui disent n'importe
quoi et qui menacent la démocratie
souvent les journalistes et les
politiques c'est un peu un peu opposés
dans le monde que j'ai connus pour les
politiques déjà en lice et s attend et
pour les gens disent les politiques
s'étaient dit oui et aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que face à tous ces dangers
on a on a au moins un combat commun et
que le monde a changé de ce point de vue
là en a - comment qu'on va commencer
qu'on n'est plus là simplement pour
faire vivre la démocratie parce que
c'est notre rôle au sein et autour d'une
façon différente plus là simplement pour
charger la démocratie mais pour défendre
la démocratie plus là pour faire vivre
nos institutions plus seulement là pour
observer nos institutions mais là pour
défendre nos institutions
clés je crois que les parisiens moi je
vis comme sénateur la moitié de la
semaine à paris et la moitié des
semaines dans mon département de
l'allier et en tant que parisien jean et
en plus j'habite entre république et
nation
les manifs le blocage de paris tous les
parisiens en ont marre ils en ont marre
beaucoup aussi beaucoup d'autres choses
mais enfin je vais pas rentrer dans la
politique
casser du sucre sur la mer de près mais
les parisiens on
[Musique]
oui enfin c'est pas la chienlit jeu que
dure on n'est pas dans la chienlit
mais je met effectivement siro luministe
de l'intérieur de faire en sorte qu'on
n'y soit pas je vois bien voir le succès
ou le non succès selma évasion mais
franchement le périph bloqué par les
camions le centre de paris bloquée par
les manifestants franchement je le dis
pour les gens qui n'habitent pas à paris
qui ne seront peut-être pas compte tous
les jours mais il ya d'autres villes et
à d'autres villes de france où si vous
êtes du sud ouest à bordeaux c'est des
choses qui arrivent
[Musique]
donc en tout cas moi j'en ai marre
emmanuel macron et et hier à belfort
pour annoncer son plan pour l'avenir
énergétique de la france alors emmanuel
macron et la conseille son quinquennat
on fait moins en fermant fessenheim et
termine en disant on va construire 14 et
on va arrêter de fermer les réacteurs
existants qui sont en état de marche on
est quand même sur un revirement total
alors si on est aux besoins macron on
dit c'est un revirement total et a pris
les maladies si on prend si on est pro
macro ont dit y a que les imbéciles qui
ne changent pas d'avis et par conséquent
il lui a fallu il
le fait aujourd'hui où il ya une
opportunité qu'il s'est trompé
si vous publiez ça c'est beaucoup plus
comment dire
nous vivons
nous vivons depuis 30 ans dans une sous
les oukases écologistes qui nous disent
les seules solutions qui nous ont qui
nous interdisent depuis qu'ils ont
réussi et c'est rien par rapport à
l'allemagne si nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans cette situation sur le plan de prix
du gaz etc c'est grâce à une politique
dramatique que l'allemagne sévères
imposées par les écologistes en guerre
américain s'est fait imposer pour les
écologistes il ya 30 ans 20 ans donc la
hausse du prix du gaz aujourd'hui que
chacun subit ou dit c'est adressez vous
aux écologistes c'est la faute des
écologistes
le raisonnement est assez
est assez long la hausse du prix du gaz
elle est due à une conjonction de
facteurs et les due à une politique
de l'allemagne qui a fermé ses centrales
nucléaires qui maintenant est l'objet de
recourir au gaz et au charbon et qui est
totalement dépendante et qui fait monter
les prix bien entendu elle est due
deuxièmement à l'action de poutine qui y
trouvent à lui un moyen inattendue est
une opportunité pour lui de casser un
peu plus l'europe et de et de faire
souffrir l'europe de de casser le cren
en supprimant avec north stream de son
sont à terme son son 'pipeline' et au
fait que nous avons alors que la france
y échappe encore parce que même en ayant
fermer une centrale en n'ayant pas
entretenu un certain nombre d'aller dans
une sur moins bonnes qu'elles ne
pourraient y est mais enfin on est quand
même heureusement dans une situation
meilleure que beaucoup de pays européens
mais il n'empêche que en ce qui concerne
le gaz parce que nous utilisons quand
même une partie du gaz pour notre
énergie bas nous souffrons comme les
autres 2
oui oui c'est c'est parce que pourquoi
est on fermer des centrales nucléaires
parce que depuis 40 ans les écolos en
france comme dans tous les pays
développés ont réussi à persuader les
gens que l'énergie nucléaire s'était mal
qu'il n'y avait pas de solution et
je pense effectivement que la fermeture
par exemple de fessenheim n'était pas
une
ici qu'il ait compris à qui des enfin
compris qu'il fallait maintenant et
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est il l'a
touchée mais ben brik il il faut mettre
les bouchées doubles peu de mayo rey
yannick jadot le candidat écologiste a
justement été très critiquée suite aux
annonces et emmanuel macron il dénonce
une voix pas c'est une voie coûteuse et
surtout une impasse sur la question des
déchets est ce que vous répondez aux
candidats écologistes justement l'a bien
compris que vous dénonciez les élus les
oukases des verts là c'est une ces deux
mondes qui s'affrontent ces deux
théories qui s'affrontent je suis ce que
je dis c'est que je dis que enfin
pour être branché pour être moderne etc
au cours des trente dernières années il
fallait être il fallait être écolo et
antinucléaires moi je pense qu'il faut
être aujourd'hui écolo mais en sachant
que les les solutions au développement
durable ce sont les solutions
scientifiques ce ne sont pas les y
compris sur les déchets nucléaires où on
fait des ont fait des avancées vous le
savez sans doute depuis la science fait
aujourd'hui en matière de traitement des
déchets des progrès considérables et
l'épaule et je pense que d'ici 20 ans 30
ans les débats que nous avons
aujourd'hui seront derrière nous donc je
dis je me félicite qu'aujourd'hui enfin
pour les politiques comme pour les
autres on puisse dire le nucléaire fait
partie pas le seul mais fait partie des
solutions développement durable sans
être traité de ne sans être traité de
danty d'anti développe d'anti
développement durable
moi je me félicite de chat et on voit
bien que ce mouvement est en train de se
faire et que tout le monde et la france
est la première à comprendre l'allemagne
mettra encore du temps le comprends mais
ils finiront par le comprendre et et par
comprendre qu'ils ont pris beaucoup
beaucoup d'années de retard dans ce
domaine claude malhuret vous avez vous
qui l'eût cru tout à l'heure je courais
sur la question internationale un débat
parlementaire se tiendra dans dix jours
sur la question du mali notre
ambassadeur au mali a été expulsée ou
savait qu est ce qu elle est votre
position est ce qu'il faut partir on
sait que cette question du départ de
barkan est sur la table évidemment c'est
un sujet qui supporte mal les raccourcis
mais en quelques
la lueur de ce débat parlementaire qui
se profile alors je pense que il n'ya
pas de bonne solution aux manies et je
pense qu'elle n'a jamais eue rappelez
vous pourquoi est-ce qu'on est au mali
parce que il ya quelques années une
colonne de djihadistes était en train de
rouler se sont pas ma direction de
bamako et qu'on les a arrêtés à la
dernière minute donc c'était déjà pas
une c'était déjà pas terrible et c'était
pas et il n'y avait pas de bonne
solution on appris la moins mauvaise et
ce genre de souci non aujourd'hui il y
aurait un califat islamiste au mali
c'est quand même s'il faut réussir à
sortir biennale donc il n'ya pas de
bonne solution
je pense je n'irai pas
les passages de cette façon là qu'il
faut sortir du mali mais de toute façon
je pense que dans quelques heures nous
ne ferons plus au mali je pense que la
seule solution aujourd'hui c'est cdu
c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait l'armée
française et de redéployer notre
dispositif anti jihadiste sur le sur le
niger
le burkina faso c'est plus compliqué
gauche ou de l'est surtout surtout
surtout parce que la silicone utilisés
il voit beaucoup de bonnes solutions
mais la situation n'est pas très bonne
non plus et surtout ce qui me préoccupe
c'est pas seulement le mali le niger le
burkina faso s'est pas seulement le sel
c'est que les groupes jihadistes sont en
train en ce moment de se rapprocher des
deux pays qui économiquement et
politiquement et diplomatiquement sont
extrêmement importants pour l'eau pour
l'occident est bon la france je parle
notamment de la côte d'ivoire je parle
de du sénégal afrique de l'ouest a
priori ne parlons même pas du nigeria ou
qu'ils aient déjà avec boko haram en
train d'être explosé dans le nord du
pays pas relayé par des djihadistes donc
il faut aujourd'hui sur redéployés et il
faut penser à préserver une autre
ceinture sur laquelle jusqu'à présent on
n'avait pas trop de craintes et
maintenant les craintes sont là comme
ailleurs et on va parler de la
présidentielle jeunes d'horizons c'est
le parti des douars fine et vous avez vu
ces dernières heures eric woerth
rejoindre emmanuel macron natacha
bouchart la maire de calais appelé
également à voter pour emmanuel macron
finalement emmanuel maintenant il n'a
pas besoin des douars filet pour aller
les gens de droite est ce que cette
décision et n'affaiblisse pas edouard
philippe au sein de la majorité
je pense surtout qu'elle
j'illustre le fait qu'il ait eu raison
avant les autres parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'horizon c'est
d'anciens adhérents d'anciens militants
d'anciens politique du centre droit
essentiellement d'ailleurs deux des
républicains qui ont compris avant les
autres qu'il y avait aujourd'hui un vrai
problème à l air qui avait d'un côté
toute une frange regarder 40% bourhis
otis est très clair toute une france qui
étaient prêts à voter au deuxième tour
pour eric zemmour et qui par conséquent
sont attiré par l'extrême droite et
toute une frange qui est pour des
solutions démocratiques pour des
notamment pour emmanuel macron c'est le
cas d'horizon puisque d'or philippe
soutien aux gens donc moi je l'analyse
pas comme le fait que le rôle d'edouard
philippe et après tout si aujourd'hui
des gens viennent etc c'est aussi parce
que il a montré le chemin c'est aussi
parce que parce qu'il est là parce qu'il
n'ya pas ce qu'il à horizon peut-être
d'ailleurs c'est un séminaire claude
malhuret exactement donc je vous avais
pris la conclusion que l air c'est
terminé j'ai bien écouté on va voir ça à
la présidentielle si
pécresse ne gagne pas la présidentielle
personne ne sait aujourd'hui ce qui va
se passer mais si elle gagne la
présidentielle va avoir beaucoup de mal
on le voit bien dans la campagne à faire
le grand écart et à réunir
les deux pôles de sa de son parti et si
le droit tiré comme ici elle n'y va pas
je pense effectivement que comme vous
dites de droite deviendra
irréconciliables d'ailleurs elles sont
irréconciliables depuis que jacques
chirac a dit
il ya trente ans il ya un mur entre la
droite et l'extrême droite ce mur il a
toujours il a toujours tenu et
aujourd'hui si
aujourd'hui il continuera à tenir mais
c'est il est en train de passer à
l'intérieur de l air et c'est l'argent
ça finirait ça signifierait probablement
l'éclatement de hennaoui est ce que
cette décision alors peut-être que
peut-être sans doute l air reste une
partie du lr restera celle qui ne
rejoindra pas avec sa droite mais qui
sera encore plus affaiblie qu elle est
aujourd
hui une partie rejoindre l emmanuel
macron bien entendu une partie régionale
sait déjà qu'à vous venez d'en parler
une partie au jour avec sa droite et une
petite partie et c'est radio j
sans doute est-ce que quand même ces
décisions un dériveur de natacha
bouchart la vôtre horizons ça risque pas
de faire passer emmanuel macron comme le
candidat de la droite ce que lui
reprochent une partie de ses opposants -
ça m'est égal moi je suis dans
la droite pour moi il a dû centrer c'est
le candidat de plus en plus du centre
droit mais je dirais non c'est pas le
candidat lui-même on est candidats de ce
conte ce moment dit que ma croûte se
revendique pas de
il a été un président qui a commencé
plus à gauche qu'il n'a fini mais en
même temps la société française
tout au long de ces dernières années la
société français s'est droitisée donc
les forces politiques suivent ce
mouvement toi en tant que sénateur et
puis président du groupe des
indépendants vous attendez les sénateurs
aient l'air vous l'avez déjà distribué
les cartes vous leur dites vous alors on
n'est pas des on n'est pas des vautours
et on n'est pas des naufrageurs ma phase
i si eric woerth par exemple contre sa
carte à horizon
et les gens le ressentent leur rock vous
dites la société droite et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous comprenez les scores
en tout cas dans les sondages de marine
le pen et surtout d'eric zemmour
vous savez je suis c'est ce que je
disais d'ailleurs si vous analysez les
scores de l'ex à noter l'excellent parce
que pour moi entre les il n'y a pas une
feuille de cigarette entre entre les
salles aux raids ex envol pour moi c'est
la même chose je le dis depuis toujours
le communisme le fascisme c'est pareil
ça fait 102 70 80 ça dure c'est ce sont
des femmes ce sont des antidémocrates
ils veulent casser le système la seule
chose qui des dividendes et en
définitive aujourd'hui entre mélenchon
et le pen c'est l'immigration pour tout
le reste ils sont d'accord ils sont
d'accord sur poutine pour soutenir
poutine ils sont d'accord sur les
programmes économiques absolument
aberrant et c'est donc ces voix là pour
moi il ya effectivement le clivage le il
ya d'une part le clivage mois d'août qui
restent mais qui s'atténue et de voir le
guidage démocrate populiste qui est en
france comme ailleurs de entend devenir
le clivage principal c'est assez simple
il sauf que comme en france on a une
tradition révolutionnaire etc on a une
ex des extrêmes qui sont divisés entre
extrême droite et extrême gauche alors
regagné leur pays c'est que le destin
droite parce qu'ils n'ont pas cette
tradition en 1893 voilà mes mais au
total ils étaient à cannes comme on
disait tout à l'heure c'est pas là moi
je ne vois pas de monter je vois une
division de ses fortes entre
40% et autres lecteurs
claude malhuret sont pas certaine
d'avoir leurs parrainages françois
bayrou veut créer une banque départ et
n'a justement pour que la démocratie
haye à son terme est-ce que vous
soutenez cette initiative moi je le
vends prends acte je suis je suis
partage vraiment soutien je suis partagé
parce que je me dis que si des extrêmes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas capables de
convaincre 500 maires de leur donner le
parrainage et si les maires ont peur en
âge d'être mal vu de leurs électeurs et
bien c'est que leurs électeurs ils ont
pas envie et c'est que c'est assez
honteux en définitive de soutenir
l'extrême droite où les symboles telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui donc après
tout allait leur pâle heureux alors je
comprends l'idée des barreaux qui est de
dire ça ferait sans doute les sondages
au qu'il ya dix ans après ça ce sera 4
mai mais il peut mais franchement je me
dis pourquoi aller soutenir des gens qui
n'en sont même pas capables de trouver
500 maires pour les soutenir parce
qu'ils ont honte de le faire merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]